[Music]
black lives matter has become a global
movement from peaceful protests that
involve
thousands to painted murals that cover
city streets
co-founder alicia garza helped coin the
phrase back in 2013 with a facebook post
this fall she was named one of time
magazine's 100 most
influential people with fellow movement
founders
go patrice cullers and opal to metty now
the activist is sharing lessons on how
to bring people together and create
change in her new book it's called
the purpose of power how we come
together when we fall apart and alicia
garza joins us now alicia
hello hello i read your book over the
weekend and after reading your book that
is the perfect title i want to say let's
start with
july 13th july 13 2013.
17 year old trayvon martin had been
killed by a neighborhood vigilante
who decided to take the law into his own
hands
you wrote at the time you cried and you
were angry you cried for his mother
sabrina fulton and then you cried for
america
and you wrote this black people i love
you i love you as us
our lives matter you never intended for
that to become a movement or a hashtag
what happened after that
well after that patrice and opal and i
got together and tried to figure out how
to
harness some of the energy that we were
seeing online
and get people to take action together
offline
of course we are not the only people who
were trying to figure that out i think
there were organizations across the
country
who were also trying to figure out how
to get people to take action
but you didn't even know what a hashtag
was alicia
no i didn't at all and you know i
thought it was a pound sign because
that's the generation i'm from
but i can say this gail we didn't have
any idea that this would spread
globally but i think we're really
honored and i know i'm honored to be
the smallest piece of something so big
and so powerful
and now it's been described by some some
critics who describe it as a terrorist
organization a marxist movement and you
say that the words have consequences
when it's portrayed that way
well it's definitely true i mean so many
people know what happens online but very
few have a peek into what's happening
offline
that's really what this book is about
and i do i talk about the political
conditions that we're living in
and under this administration we have
been subject to
all kinds of attacks i get death threats
every day i know patrice does as well
and there are so many activists like me
you're getting desperate
wait you're getting death every single
day i get death threats and so
i think it's important for people to
understand what does it mean for us to
be the kind of country
where this doesn't happen to folks who
are trying to change rules that have
been rigged against our communities for
such a long time
and that's really what this book gets
into it's a
it's a reflection for me on the things
that i've learned
the things that i'm unlearning and the
things i'm still learning and i hope
that it will be a helpful tool
for people who are trying to figure out
how to get started or
for people who are trying to figure out
how to keep going i like how you say
hashtags do not build a movement
people build a movement and you can't
sustain a movement with anger and grief
what do you mean by that that's right
well i think there's so much emphasis
that's placed on social media
and i get asked all the time you know
how do i build a social media following
so that i can build a movement
and i have to explain to folks right
that movements fundamentally
are first and foremost about getting
more power to more people
but it's also about impacting people
where they are
and building relationships offline as
well as
online you know it's important for me
for people to understand
that what we're up against right now
requires a deepening of our
relationships
it requires us doing addition and
multiplication
rather than subtraction and division and
hashtags don't do that
only people can accomplish that but for
a lot of people you know this they look
at the black lives matter movement they
see looting they see burning they see
destruction
i want you to address that and i want
you to address too because people are
upset when they think black lives matter
is a point the point you make throughout
the book
black lives matter does not negate the
significance of people who are not black
because people say all lives matter
which is true
it is true but if all lives mattered
then we wouldn't have black lives not
mattering
and i think one of the things that i say
in the book is that
it's important for us to be able to tell
our own stories that's part of why i
wrote this book so many people
talk about black lives matter without
talking to the people who are helping to
push it forward and when it comes to the
perceptions of protests in this country
i mean vice news ran a story just a
couple of weeks ago that said that 97
of black lives matter protests are
peaceful and in the three percent where
they're not it's often because there
are people who are not protesters who
are bringing guns to protests
one of the things that we don't talk
enough about is the presence of white
militias
in our protest the presence of racial
terror that is also being advanced
by this president we saw him on a
national stage say to a white
nationalist group
to stand back and stand by and so in my
book i talk about the stories that we
have to tell
that are more accurate and rooted in our
communities all right elisa you said
what happens when we come together thank
you very much
we'll be right back thanks so much gil